if I have to bake another cake
anytime soon after this
I may as well open a bakery
and I feel like if I've said it once
I've said it a thousand times
but it's birthday season
and today we're celebrating a special
someone who's turning the big 15
we're going for a fluffy vanilla sponge
with a berry coulis centre
because their favourite colour is pink
I first met them back in 2014 and we've had a
lot of really good times together
which mainly involved keeping the lights on
and I don't know if you've ever tried to play a
birthday game with a
non physical entity before but
musical chairs, pass the parcel and
pin the electricity bolt on the mascot
were all epic fails
so it's a good thing Powershop have given us
the birthday games this time
the games are surprisingly addictive
and there's a bunch of really cool prises up for grabs
including free power and you don't even need to be a customer to play
just head on over aim for a high score and you could win big